Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
I'm back today.
It's almost the end of October, but that means...
I can fit one more spooky game into the month.
So today, we're gonna be playing...
Finding... Sorry, I almost legitimately forgot the game.
I was like, what the fuck is the game called?
I had to look at my...
I had to look at the title of my stream!
I was like... It was like something Frankie.
Finding Frankie!
Yes!
Okay, so...
It is the next...
It is another mascot horror game.
Because apparently, that's all we do these days.
Like, it's either rebooting old...
Rebooting or remastering classic horror games.
Or the mascot horror genre.
So, Finding Frankie is another mascot horror game.
But the twist is that we are parkouring.
That's the twist.
It's basically like...
What if Fall Guys...
But it's scary.
So, that's the whole game.
It's scary parkour.
Horror Fall Guys.
Apparently, it's also...
It's also like a mascot horror genre.
So, that's also like the other twist in the mascot horror genre.
Look, not every game could be Garden of Bon Bon, guys.
Not every game can be just as good as Garden of Bon Bon.
The fucking masterpiece.
With their 4 billion triangles.
Doctor, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Sympathy Raptor, will you...
Oh, wait.
Is this a marriage proposal?
No, don't marry that guy.
No, not him.
Anyway, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Poor...
Don't keep...
No, you guys are supposed to pay attention to me.
Marriage proposal in my chat?
Anyway, I'm joking, I'm joking.
Okay, what are you saying?
Sympathy Raptor, will you marry Doctor Genzo?
You know, there's no...
No pressure, no pressure.
Are you even in my chat?
Oh, it would be so awkward if you're not even watching.
That would be...
Oh, but Doki, don't make...
Wait, you're right.
Alright, I'll only allow this marriage proposal if you name the child after me.
That's so fucked up, Doki.
Like, that child's gonna get bullied for the rest of their life.
Look, look, it's like those parents that named their kid after Naruto.
I'll only allow this marriage proposal to go through if you name your child after me.
That's all.
I could be a middle name, guys.
Like, I'm willing to compromise and even let you, like, give it as, like, a middle name.
That's it.
That's, like, the compromise I'm willing to take.
Like, it has to be a legal name.
It has to be a full legal name.
And then, like, I wanna see that person's birth certificate in my tags later.
Dox your baby now, right after.
What do you mean?
Doki can be a fucking middle name.
It's genderless.
It does not have male or female gender to it.
It's, like, such a gender-neutral fucking name.
What are you talking about?
Yes, I can make these demands.
It's literally my...
What do you mean, I can't make these demands?
It's my channel.
If you wanna do a marriage proposal on my channel, you gotta name...
I'm, like, Rumpelstiltskin.
Instead of giving me, like, your firstborn child, you have to name your child after me.
Anyway, where was I?
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, yeah, I was talking about the game.
Anyway, life update.
So, okay, I have a lot of life updates, actually.
So, I bought a kettle.
You know, we bought it together, chat.
We bought the kettle together.
But the thing is, oh, my God.
It's the same kettle I saw at the close, like, local drug mart.
Okay, like, I know that sounds fucking weird.
But, like, if you guys don't know what, like, London Drugs is, that...
It's, like, that's what we call, like, those, like...
Like, those, you know, those marketplaces.
Like, those, like, you know, miniature marketplaces in Canada.
So, like, you know, it has everything.
It has everything, yeah.
It has... It's not, like...
It has, like, appliances.
Yeah, it's, like, a pharmacy.
But, like, it has everything.
It's not just for medicine.
It has, like, appliances, kitchen appliances.
Um...
CVS, yes, yes!
It's, like, Walgreens slash CVS in Canada.
Anyway, never knew Canada was chill like that.
I was so... I was, like, I was so fucking mad.
Because, like, you know, I ordered it off of Amazon.
But, like, it was literally the same kettle I saw at my local, like, I guess, pharmacy.
I don't know!
I don't know what it's called in American.
In American.
And, like, um...
Anyway, so, like, uh...
And it was, like, the same one I saw there.
But it was, like, $30 cheaper.
Because it was on sale.
So, I was, like, are you fucking...
I was, like, I could have just...
I was literally there.
And I was, like, no, I'm just gonna go Amazon it.
It might be, like...
They might have a better version.
And, like, it could be cheaper.
But it was literally the same one.
I was looking at that box, too.
Before I decided to, like, buy it on Amazon.
Like, I was looking at the same box.
I was debating.
I was, like, oh, do I want to carry this all the way home?
Like, it is, like, pretty far.
But I was, like, oh, but it is light.
And I was, like, debating it for the longest fucking time.
And then I was, like, no more order on Amazon.
Clearly, like, they have better brands.
And it could be cheaper.
And then...
I could have got it 30...
Oh, my God.
I feel, like, such an adult now.
I'm, like, thinking about, like, oh, my God.
I could have got it $30 cheaper.
I say as I pay $1,000 for a commission.
Like...
I'm just, like, oh, my God.
I could have spent 30...
I could have spent $20 on this kettle instead of $50.
I say as I go on PayPal and do...
Pay for this no budget commission right now.
But, yeah.
But, anyway, I was really happy.
I was really happy I finally got a kettle.
Because that meant I can finally make my spicy noodles.
You know, the Buldak.
Samyang Buldak noodles.
I was so excited.
Because, like, I even went...
Because I've been getting those, like...
I've been missing the spicy noodles for a long time.
I usually call it spicy nudes.
But then, like, I realized context-wise I shouldn't say that on stream.
So, I'm just gonna call...
I usually be, like, man...
Like, to my friends, I'd be, like, I can't wait to get some spicy nudes.
But I was, like, I shouldn't say that to you guys.
Anyway.
Anyway, so I was, like, super excited.
Because I was, like, I haven't had them in a long time.
Because, you know, I didn't have a fucking kettle.
So, I also didn't have, like, pots or, like...
I didn't have any pots or, like, plates.
Or, like, bowls or anything.
Like, I only have paper plates and wooden utensils.
Like, I don't even have chopsticks or anything.
So, anyway.
I was super excited.
So, I was looking at, like, you know, Uber Eats to be, like...
Because I wanted to buy, like, the cup noodle version.
I wanted to buy the cup noodle version of, like, Samyang Buldak noodles.
So, they're, like, Korean spicy noodles.
And, like, you know, the one with the chicken on it.
And so, I was, like, trying to Uber Eat it.
Because, like, the supermarkets that sell them are, like, really far away.
So, I was, like, I'm just gonna Uber Eats.
So, but they only had, like...
The thing is, they don't have the cup noodle version.
They have the package version.
So...
I was, like...
Fuck.
I don't wanna buy pots.
You know.
I didn't wanna buy pots and pans and a bowl just for that.
Because, like, you know, I'm, like, living the fucking bachelor life here.
I'm literally, like...
I'm literally living, like, with, like, no utensils.
No utensils.
No...
No bowls.
No pots.
No pans.
No kitchen supplies.
Like, it's just a microwave and a kettle.
I do have, like, an oven and, like, you know, an oven and, like, what's the top part called?
The top part of the oven where you boil water.
Fuck!
Stove!
I have a stove.
Look, guys.
It's been a while.
I have a stove.
I have an oven.
I just don't use it.
I have a dishwasher.
I just don't use it because I don't have any of the things that require me to use it.
So...
So I was like, oh, man, I want to buy, like, a cup noodle of the Samyang Buldak noodles.
So I was like, there's, like, a local convenience store nearby.
So I went down there.
But then they also don't have the cup noodle version.
Because I was like, oh, none of the Uber Eats places have them.
Like, they have it, but it doesn't have the specific flavor that I want, which is carbonara.
I love the carbonara Buldak flavor the most.
And I was, like, craving for that.
Because I was like, kettle!
Yeah!
So, the convenience store...
It's the pink one.
Actually had them.
But it was...
I'm using my very first Super Chat to beg you to please buy dinnerware.
Noah, thank you for your very first Super Chat.
Thank you.
But, like, if I have plates and bowls, that requires me to wash them.
If I finish eating it, I can throw it in the trash can.
I can throw it into compost because it's made of paper.
It can be recycled.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Next scene.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
You can buy Buldak noodles online.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
But I want it now!
That's the thing.
I wanted it now.
So...
By the way, I still haven't picked up my trash can.
It's, like, down in the lobby still.
And, like, they actually texted me.
The lobby...
The concierge downstairs actually texted me.
And was like, please pick up your packages.
Because, like, we need the room for other packages for the other residents.
That was two days ago.
Yesterday, I did go downstairs to pick up the kettle.
But I was like...
They were like, do you want to pick up this?
I was like, no, I'll pick it up later.
I'll come back downstairs to pick it up.
I'm going to pick up this first.
I didn't go back downstairs.
I...
I didn't say when I was going to come back.
Okay?
Eventually...
Eventually, I'll pick it up.
But I got the kettle.
I went downstairs.
There was a trash can.
And I was like, oh, I don't have enough hands for both boxes.
So, let me just pick this first.
And then, I'll come back downstairs to pick up the other stuff.
Anyway...
Pick it up now, Doki.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway...
Anyway, so...
This is my solution regarding the spicy noodles.
So, you see...
I don't have a bowl.
See, that was my biggest problem.
I didn't have a bowl.
So, I was like, how am I going to make the carbonara spicy noodles if I don't have a bowl for this?
If it's not in cup noodle form.
And I don't have, like, a pot.
So, what I did...
Look, it's all about working smarter.
What I did was I saw there was the big shin ramen cup noodles that they do have.
So, I bought one of the shin ramen cup noodles.
And I just went back home.
I opened it and just took out the ramen inside.
And then transferred the bowl of noodles into...
I just needed the cup, you see.
All I needed was the cup.
So, I took the ramen noodles out.
Instant noodles out.
Put the bowl of noodles in.
And I even have the flap to cover it up to heat up the noodles.
Anyway, it's not like I'm not going to use the shin ramen instant noodles another time.
Just that I just wanted to eat the bowl of noodles first.
So, yay!
What's that phrase called?
Something requires modern solutions.
Modern problems require modern solutions.
So, that's what I did.
I also bought mozzarella cheese.
Because I've been watching a lot of Korean convenience store shorts.
I don't even watch TikTok.
I watch shorts, which is basically people stealing content from TikTok and putting it on YouTube.
So, I've been watching a lot of Korean convenience store shorts.
And they always get those mozzarella cheese.
And they put it on top of the bowl of noodles.
And then they microwave the noodles after all of that.
And it's always looked so good.
So, I did that too.
And it was actually really good.
That was a really good life hack right there.
I also ended up going to the regular market.
Because I wanted to buy the mozzarella cheese.
Because I was like, you know what?
I already went through the hassle of buying the noodles.
I might as well go for the full Korean convenience store experience.
And then go to a regular supermarket to buy mozzarella cheese.
And some meat and stuff to put on it.
And everything.
Not eggs though.
I tend to buy eggs.
But I didn't have a pan.
And then I was like, oh my god.
I don't want to just cook the egg in the microwave.
I didn't trust myself.
I was like, you know what?
I'm already sort of barely living right now with what I'm doing.
So, I shouldn't push the boundaries.
So, I almost did.
I was like, I shouldn't push the boundaries here.
So, I did it.
So, I did not do that.
I'm not boiling the egg.
I meant like cracking the egg and putting it in the soup.
And then microwaving it.
Like with the noodles.
That's what I was thinking about.
But then like, you know, rational thought came in clutch at that last moment.
I was like, that might not be a good idea.
You're already pushing the boundaries here by like, you know, by everything else you do in life.
And then because I was at the supermarket, there was bread.
Like there was a bread knife.
Like I was literally looking through stuff.
I was like, oh my god.
There's a bread knife right here.
You know what?
I have so much bread.
At this point, this is just an investment.
So, you guys know how...
You guys...
Everybody was like...
I posted a photo on Twitter of like me and my bread knife.
And like...
First off, I'm not bad at cutting bread.
It was my first time cutting bread.
But I'm not bad at cutting bread.
The reason the bread looked like that was because...
I told you guys.
I was ripping the bread with my fingers.
And also using a wooden cutter knife.
Like those disposable wooden knives.
So, I was using that to cut my bread.
And then, you know...
I would cut it halfway.
Because it's like a fucking wooden knife.
And then I would rip it with my hands.
Because I was like...
I live alone.
Who's gonna know?
But then because I told that story to you guys on stream.
I was getting judged.
And I was like...
Maybe I should reintegrate into society.
And so, I bought a bread knife.
And now...
Now, you guys are judging me for my lack of plates.
But it's like...
Why do I need plates?
If I could just, you know...
Not use actual plates.
And just use my paper plates.
Because after I'm done eating...
I can recycle the plates and not wash them.
I don't have to think about them no more.
Like...
You'll never be satisfied.
There's always a new problem.
JL, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
My kami-oshi is the ultimate girl failure.
I can't believe it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Waste is so waste.
Well, it's paper.
You can recycle paper.
It's not like I'm throwing it in the trash, trash.
They have...
There's like 200 different types of like...
Trash cans.
Like the big trash cans.
Like...
For the building.
And like it's all marked and everything.
And they're like...
If you don't sort your trash out properly...
We're gonna find you.
So...
So I actually try my best...
To like sort the trash properly.
Because they're like...
We're gonna find you if you don't sort out your trash.
Anyway.
Okay, I'm back.
Okay.
Okay, maybe they found me.
Maybe...
Okay.
There might...
I did maybe once or twice.
I didn't sort my trash.
It was just once or twice.
Okay, I was...
Feeling particularly...
Very lazy.
And I put everything in one...
One trash bag.
And I was like...
I am tired.
I don't wanna sort my trash right now.
I...
Okay.
Okay, I admit.
I did lie.
It was a tiny lie.
It was like once or twice.
Maybe three times.
Okay, I lived here for like...
Three to four months already.
Look, I...
I admit.
Maybe...
Maybe it wasn't just once or twice.
Maybe it was three times.
I lived here for so long.
Like, I could have a freebie.
Maybe several freebies.
Anyway.
There's my bread knife.
You can even see...
Dad's feet right here.
Cause he was like...
Ooh, bread.
Maybe it was four to five.
Who's keeping count?
You're not keeping count.
I'm not keeping count.
Who's keeping count right now?
And yes, I'm cutting it on a paper plate.
It makes no difference to me.
People are like, you should get a cutting board.
Or like, you should get a real plate.
It makes no difference.
It's a plate.
It works.
I did not struggle.
I put chop, chop, chop, slice, slice.
It worked.
It had no issues at all.
I had no issues cutting...
Cutting the bread.
Yes, it does.
It's not even...
It's paper.
It's just...
It's just bread.
It does not make any difference to me.
Anyway.
So...
That was today's life update.
It's not a sad life update.
Like, I'm slowly reintegrating into society.
Like, it's not an ugly cut.
I told you.
This is where I ripped the bread.
This is before.
That area right here.
The missing...
That area right here where it's missing.
Right here.
This is where I had no knife.
So, I was ripping the bread.
I was ripping the bread.
So, like...
Because of that...
The bread was not very...
You know...
Was not very full.
Because I was just ripping it into pieces.
And using my wooden knife.
Because I was like...
Who's gonna know?
Like...
I live by myself.
Who's gonna fucking know that that's how I eat bread?
And then...
I was like...
You know what?
I'm gonna tell my chat about my lovely bread story.
And then...
Instead...
Of being like...
Haha.
What a funny, lovely bread story.
Everybody was like...
Get a fucking bread knife.
So, I...
So, I came in the peer pressure.
Because I was like...
Maybe this isn't normal.
You know?
Maybe what I'm doing...
Isn't normal.
Maybe I should buy a bread knife.
And be like...
A normal human being.
So...
I bought a bread knife.
And now you guys are complaining about my plates.
So like...
What do you want from me?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It makes me sad to hear you living like a fucking caveman.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Cookies, thank you for the super chat.
Just take my money and get supplies.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We were expecting the bare minimum, Doki.
This isn't the bare minimum.
You did not even reach it.
Like...
Alright.
So, yeah.
That was...
That's my life update.
That's really it.
That's all I wanted to talk about regarding today's life.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Do you own a broom and dustpan?
Do you own pots?
I told you I don't have pots and pans.
That's why I bought a separate cup noodle.
Because I don't have a bowl or a pot to boil my noodles.
So I have to buy a separate cup noodle.
Dissect that.
Take away its innards.
And then transfer...
Do like a noodle transplant into the cup to make my spicy noodles.
No, I don't have...
I need to buy a...
I need to buy like those little robot cleaners.
What are they called?
The little robot guys that clean the floor for you automatically.
I need to buy that.
The Roombas.
Yes.
But the thing is, first off, I need to unpack first.
I need to get a Roomba.
But it's like step by step.
Because I need to unpack and like clean my office space and the rest of my living situation.
So I can justify buying a Roomba.
Because if I buy a Roomba now, the Roomba's gonna be like, where the fuck do I go?
It's gonna be like...
Why do I...
Why am I here?
What...
How do I clean when I...
There's no space to clean.
So...
So I got...
It's like one step at a time type deal right now.
I mostly unpack the office space.
But like...
It's sort of not actually unpacked.
But like my PC's here.
Like I can work.
That's...
That's good.
NPC, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
For my birthday, could you get yourself a cutting board instead of singing?
Hope you have a spooky time with Frankie.
Thank you for your super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear NPC.
Yeah!
Okay.
Anyway.
Alright, time...
Okay, now you guys can stop judging me.
It's time to play video games.
It's time to escape reality, guys.
Yeah, video games!
It's time to escape reality.
Let's go.
I love video games.
Run away from the real world.
Let's find Frankie, guys.
Let's go.
Rin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Roomba had not seen such a room before.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Let's see.
I did some...
Oh, wait.
There's a speed run timer?
Wait, really?
Oh my god, that's funny.
What does it look like?
What is the speed run time?
Nah, we don't need to do a speed run here.
Okay, head bobbing off.
I hate head...
What the fuck is a body?
Like, what is that?
Oh, that's me!
Okay, let me move some stuff around.
So I can like, see the screen properly.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Guys, it's time to play video games.
Forget about the real world.
We're here to forget about the real world now.
It's time for video games.
My life is not a mess.
Mmm.
Oh, hey.
Frankie's Fruit Flakes.
Morning Crunch.
Do people still eat cereal?
I feel like there's so many like, better alternatives now than cereal.
Oh my god, he's famous.
He's like Mickey Mouse before parkour.
Oh my god!
He got it!
He got the audition tape!
Oh.
Whoa.
Those are just props, right?
They're just props, guys.
Nothing to worry about.
I think like, cereal is more for like, children.
I mean, it's always been for children.
But like, I feel like there's now like, better alternatives to cereal.
I guess people want like, something quick.
So you aren't late for school and stuff like that.
Me?!
Oh my god, this is a mascot horror.
Here's the mascot horror checklist.
Uh, one.
Does it come with an animated short introducing where you are?
Giving you exposition of what's going on?
Alright, two.
Did they take something that's considered normal?
Oh, 19!
Numbers, numbers, numbers!
Oh my god, my 19k bots!
Deputy Duck Frankie.
Oh, are they all like, quirky little characters there?
With like, uh, some nine...
Some like, old classic cartoon art style.
Oh, sound is low?
Okay, let me fix that real quick.
Uh, let's see.
Alright, let's turn down the sensitivity too.
The sensitivity is so fucking high.
Holy shit.
Alright, there you go.
Oh, is this my costume?
Alright.
Attraction key.
Entrance one, plaza.
Main lobby.
Parkour room number one.
Finding Frankie is out of service.
Hexahavoc.
Parkour room.
Hide and Henry?
Oh no, I gotta hide?
Oh hey!
Oh, it's more than- Oh, it is Fall Guys!
You're all cho-chosen too?
Don't worry.
Hello, friends!
Oh my god, we're all chosen!
Today's gonna be- Oh, he's locked in.
Look at him go.
He's so locked in.
Wait, how do I know- Oh!
Woah, woah, woah!
Woah!
Woah, okay!
Okay, he was way too locked in!
He was way too locked in!
You know what?
He- Woah!
Woah!
Second- You know what they say, second's the best!
Oh my god.
Oh, okay.
He got locked out.
Alright.
Run in the doors to kick them.
Alright, now we know, guys.
It's better to not be first place.
Now we know.
Wait.
Jump in front?
Oh, we already did it?
We completed the tutorial?
Wow, that was- What?
Okay.
How do I grab this?
Oh!
Okay, I figured this out.
Watch this.
Okay.
This does not feel so natural at all.
Wait, what?
Oh my god, I have to do- Okay, while moving forward, press space to jump off.
Alright.
Oh, I have to jump to it.
I have to- Okay, this- That part doesn't feel as natural.
What?
I hit it!
I swear to god, I swear to god I did.
I hit spacebar.
Okay.
Alright.
And then...
I'm gaming.
Alright, now I figured it out.
Alright.
Safety training, return to the lobby.
How do I go back to the lobby?
Oh, this way.
Alright.
Alright, we did it, guys!
We learned how to parkour!
Now I need to figure out how to get back home.
Oh, I guess I have to parkour back?
Alright.
Must be 18- The parent pad.
Do I just go back?
I did it!
Oh, I slide so fast!
Hello!
Whoa!
Hello?
Hey guys, I did my thing.
Oh, I completed it!
So I get to be here!
Oh my god, what happened to them?
Yeah!
Oh, it's PG?!
Just like my honeypot stream!
I mean, making kids is- Does have parents involved.
Whoa!
I should give him a visit?
Alright, nice.
Alright.
What did I open?
Oh, I opened back here.
Okay.
Open the back door.
Hello?
Whoa.
I don't like- Whoa, I don't like the eyes he's giving me right now.
Please, this show is for children, sir.
Please, this is a kid's show.
I feel a little uncomfortable.
Here, you're literally a phone.
I need a key.
What did I open here?
I open this?
Oh, I did.
I had a feeling it was this.
Okay, circuit breaker.
Parkour ahead.
Okay.
I'm gonna wait until it explodes.
Cause I already fucked it.
I already fucked up the timing anyway.
Oh, wait, does it not matter?
Oh.
There we go.
Okay, it does matter.
Nice.
Wait, this game is so easy.
This is a game- This is act- What was that?
What?
What was that?
It just gave me a- I didn't even see- What was that?
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'M SO SORRY.
I'm sorry.
It gave me scary music.
What happened?
What the fuck?
Okay.
Oh my god.
This game is so easy.
I'm like- I don't- I don't- Where do I- Where do I go?
No!
Where do I hide?
I don't- No!
Instructions unclear!
Just don't fall off.
Where do I hide?
I- He said- He said hide!
Fucking where?
Just don't fall.
It's parkour, Doki.
There's no such thing as hiding in parkour.
Where do I- Where do I hide?
Okay.
Alright.
I can do this.
He doesn't know.
How would he know?
Oh, thank god.
Oh, thank god he didn't know.
Guys, he didn't know.
There was- There was no other way.
It was broken!
You guys lied to me!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
How would he know?
He can go up!
I didn't think he would look up!
He can look up.
Everybody knows gamers don't look up!
He's not a real gamer.
He wasn't a real gamer.
He's not a gamer.
Guys.
Please, I only watched the first six minutes of Parkour Civilization.
Please.
I only watched the first six minutes.
I don't know how it ends.
I just know about the chicken and beef.
Oh my god.
I'm fine.
I know you can swing, but I get too excited and I just let go.
I let go!
I can't help it!
Oh my god.
Alright.
Meet Henry Hotline and get a chance to ask him a question on his late night show.
Make your way through the Henry Museum and enter Visit Studio or go down to the Henry Household.
Who keeps ringing this phone?
Oh, he must be a nice guy.
He seems like a very nice guy.
Wait, he's like the...
Ring.
Henry?
Is Henry not gonna pick up the phone?
Why is Henry not picking up the phone?
Hello?
I thought you said Henry would call.
Henry doesn't even care.
You know what Henry looks like?
Late night show with Jimmy Fallon, right?
He looks like a Jimmy Fallon host.
Alright.
Alright, this is where the parkour is, but like, is there anything here?
Okay.
Okay, there is a trampoline.
Where's the next circuit breaker?
Out of order?
Oh fuck, oh no.
I don't know where the sec- Oh, there it is, there it is!
Okay, parkour.
Nice.
A door has been opened.
I don't know which door, but I did it.
Oh, I don't know which door.
There's so many doors.
Which door is it?
Okay.
Apparently, like...
There was like...
Jimmy Fallon actually broke character because his newest guests were like the Costco boys or what?
I don't even...
I don't even know who- I didn't think they were like a popular thing.
Like, what was it?
The Costco boys?
Oh my god, somebody help that third child.
That...
Yeah, right.
Who?
Yeah, it popped up on my Twitter.
Like, I remember seeing one video of them because Meat Canyon made like a parody thing about it.
Wait, but what's this then?
Because like Meat Canyon did a parody of like the Costco boys and that's literally the only reason why I know who they are.
We're the Co- Yeah, we're the Costco guys.
Okay, what's wrong with this?
Oh, it's a little Easter.
It's like a little collectible.
Oh no, this...
This seems Poppy Playtime.
Oh, what's wrong with that phone?
That looks like a nice phone.
That doesn't look dangerous at all.
Alright, parkour.
Parkour.
Yay, parkour.
I must be like the fucking slowest parkour right now.
Wait, where did I go?
I did the parkour.
There's more?
What parkour did I miss?
What, what parkour- Oh my god, the beginning.
The- The first button.
Alright.
Yeah, it was like, I was just like...
All I could think about is the third child.
I was like, is he okay?
Like, that's all I could think about.
Wait, whoa.
Whoa, oh, hey there.
Hey.
Hey, oh.
Want a hand?
Oh, thanks for giving me a hand.
Oh, that's sweet.
You gave me a hand.
Hold E.
Wait.
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh!
Oh, fucking...
The breaker right in front of me?
Wait.
There we go.
Nice.
I did it.
What does that open though?
Okay, follow the red line.
Oh, down here.
Must be here then.
Oh my god, I go so fast.
Ooh.
Whoa!
Who's that?
Alright.
Oh god!
He's chasing me!
Okay, I'm sliding, sliding, sliding, sliding.
Where do I go?
Where do I...
Don't touch me!
Oh.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
It's just like a deer in headlights situation.
I like see him and I was like, what do I do?
I don't know!
I feel like...
I'm like a deer!
I'm like a fucking deer when I see it!
Like, I fucking, I don't know!
I feel like...
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
I don't...
I don't do well when I'm under...
Ah!
So much pressure.
Oh my god.
I don't want him to find me no more.
I just...
I'm just like, oh my god, he's approaching me.
What do I do?
Do I just look at him?
Like...
I don't know.
I just, I'm just like...
Do I look at him?
Oh my god!
What is he looking at?
Is he looking at me?
Oh my god, please.
Like, it's not fair because I slide so fast!
Oh my god, I hear him.
I actually...
I hear him!
I can't...
I think I hate this game.
Oh my god.
I'm clicking so fast.
But you know when you click too fast...
I'm not okay.
I'm not okay, guys.
Oh my god, I'm too fast.
I'm too fast.
Everything is too fast.
Everything is...
Oh my god, I have to...
How?
Okay.
Smash!
Fuck!
Okay.
Everything is fine.
Parkour!
I'm trying!
I swear I'm not trying!
I'm...
No!
I...
Oh my god, I swear...
I swear I'm trying my best here.
I'm fucking...
I'm not trolling.
I'm not throwing intentionally.
It's just...
He's just...
How?
How is he still holding that?
I'm calm.
It's okay.
I'm...
Everything...
Ah!
That was a pretty neat...
That was a neat parkour.
It's so bad.
Well, that was it.
That wasn't...
That wasn't so bad, guys.
I'm calm.
Okay, alright.
By the way, how...
How's the sound right now, guys?
I should have asked you that.
I don't know if sound guy is alive.
I don't think he is.
I don't...
I don't think sound guy is alive.
Oh my god.
I feel so relaxed.
Right now.
Fuck, I don't...
Okay.
Let me up the game sound a little.
Here we go.
Alright.
Let's...
Let's wait a little bit.
Let's relax and...
Wait a little.
Oh, you know what?
I got this.
Where's the last one, though?
Oh!
Where could the last one...
Oh, it's over here.
How do I get up there?
Oh my god.
Oh, at least I could like relax a little bit and figure this out before anything.
How do I...
Oh, is it like here?
Wait, how do I get up there?
The thing is over here.
Where's the parkour for this?
Alright, turn down the game music.
Okay.
Alright.
Got you.
How the fuck do I...
Oh!
It's here!
Right?
Can I make that jump?
No, I don't think so.
Oh!
Gamers don't look up.
Parkour.
Okay, so that's...
Wait, there has to be a secret over there, then.
There has to be a secret, then.
Because there's like...
More to the vent jumping.
Guys, the problem why I didn't see that is because it wasn't yellow.
Like, who makes it red?
Red is bad.
That's all I'm saying.
Red is supposed to be bad, so why...
That's their fault.
Honestly.
Their fault for making it red.
Yeah, true.
Oh, we can't open.
Oh, promote.
Enjoy your time in Deputy Duck's Park.
Deputy Duck can't be that bad.
Maybe he's nice.
You know?
Maybe...
Maybe he's a nice one in the...
Maybe he's a nice guy.
Anybody that's a duck must be a nice guy, right?
Right?
Like...
We all know red is bad, like...
Alright, up we go.
Up we go.
Yeah.
There's always one nice guy.
Guys.
Okay.
There's always one nice character in each mascot horror game.
And I bet Deputy Duck is the nicest guy around.
Maybe there's something over here?
Okay.
Oh?
Oh, I'm back here!
Oh!
I gave a shortcut.
It's a little shortcut.
Oh, that means I have to go back here.
Alright.
Here we go.
Parkour.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to parkour.
Hello, I'm here to sign in for my parkour session.
Hello?
You were right.
I shouldn't have tried to eat cereal that's been in a box for 50 years.
Whoa.
Oh, he seems like a nice guy.
Hello there.
Oh, hey!
Hey there!
Hey!
Oh, hey there!
See?
I told you!
They're friendly!
I knew they were friendly.
I knew it.
There's always one friendly guy.
Look!
See?
There he is looking at me!
Nothing bad can happen with ducks.
All ducks are cool guys.
Can I die from that?
Oh god, this has to be the slowest Indiana Jones ball I've ever seen.
Okay.
Wow, so scary.
So scary.
Oh my god.
I'm so scared.
This is not a fucking horror game.
Honestly, easiest horror game of my fucking life.
Not even scared at all.
This is so calming too.
Like, I don't have to rush or anything.
I just...
I just gotta parkour.
See?
Nothing to worry about.
Wait, how do I...
Okay, there we go.
And then...
Look at that!
Nothing scary at all.
I'm not scared.
I'm so calm.
I'm so, so calm.
Hey there!
I knew you were a good guy.
Hello?
Yeah?
You okay there?
Kill me.
Kill me, please.
They made me a TV.
Deputy Duck!
Oh, that was easy.
Oh, flash.
What the fuck?
What did I do with you?
How do I use you?
You're just...
He's just two weeks from retirement.
Oh my god, he's in baby jail.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
How the fuck do I use this duck?
Oh!
Do it.
Yeah, I'm talking to you.
Come on!
Do your thing!
Oh my god.
Okay, you got...
Did I do it?
Wait, what does that do?
What does the radar do?
Why is it red?
Why is it a dangerous color?
Whoa!
Why are you dangerous?
Hyde and Henry?
Wait.
Wait, what does it...
What do you mean by Hyde and Harry, Deputy Duck?
What do you mean by that?
Deputy Duck, what does Hyde and Henry mean?
Oh no.
Hello, Henry?
Henry, is that you?
Oh, I don't like this.
Hello?
Oh.
Use to scan dark areas.
Okay.
Keep scanning.
Oh my gosh, now I'm actually scared.
Bring me back to parkour, guys.
This is Finding Frankie, not Finding Henry, guys.
Give me...
Bring me back...
Bring me back to parkour.
I think parkour was a lot more fun.
Guys.
Guys, I think I had more fun with the parkour part.
Hello?
Oh my god, Jimmy Fallon, you okay?
I just pressed one button!
Oh.
Okay.
I mean...
It doesn't seem that mad.
I don't know, he seemed okay.
Just gotta press another.
Wonder what happens if I press this.
Hehe.
But what if I press that again?
Oh my god, wait a minute, I don't like this anymore.
I don't...
Hehe.
Oh my god, what if he freaks out?
Guys, what if he starts freaking out?
Guys, do you think he's gonna freak out?
Do you think...
Do you think he's gonna freak out if I keep pressing the phone?
Do you think he's gonna...
WHAT?!
WHAT THE FUCK?!
I mean...
Guys, he's just holding my hand.
He's just...
Guys, aww, isn't that sweet?
He just wants to hold my hand, guys.
He just...
He just wants to...
Guys, he just wants to hold my hand.
Like, what do I...
Am I supposed to like...
Fucking...
Flash him?
But like...
You know what I mean, guys.
Like...
You know?
Like, am I supposed to...
Be like...
Ooh...
Oh, I don't like this.
Like, does he get scared if I flash him?
Like, I don't understand.
Oh, I don't like this part.
Ring, ring.
Is this a safe room?
This is safe, right?
Right?
I feel safe.
Deputy Duck, do something.
I feel like...
I don't feel safe anymore.
Like, I want...
Bring me back to the parkour.
I just want to parkour.
I don't feel...
It's too far.
Where's the last two?
Where is it?
Please, have comfort, quack.
Where's the last two?
Where is it?
I can't.
I don't want to get out of the safe space.
I don't want to get out of the safe space, guys.
I don't feel safe.
What the fuck is upstairs?
What the fuck is that?
Okay.
Alright, there's like one over...
Okay, the last two is like over there.
Alright.
I pressed this already?
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Womp womp.
Okay.
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
Oh, god, there he is.
Womp womp.
The last one's all the way back there.
It's so far.
Stop.
Stop, I'm gonna flash you.
Does the flash do anything to him?
I can't tell.
I'm scared.
Okay, it's like right over there.
It's literally...
It's right...
Right there.
At the very end.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Where do I escape?
What do you mean escape?
Where's the...
Where's the exit?
I never paid attention to the exit door!
Okay.
Follow the sign.
Alright.
Three.
Two.
Oh, fuck you.
Okay, I need a want-want appreciation.
I need a want-want motivation.
Want-want.
Here we go.
Give me one last want-want for the ride, deputy.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Go!
Wait, where does this go?
Where
does...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Wait, I ran back!
I got lost!
I had to...
Guys,
I got lost.
I don't know how.
I'm back to where I started.
I...
I don't...
Want-want!
I don't know how this is happening to me.
I don't know, guys.
I'm freaking out right now.
This is where I came from.
Which way did I go?
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, my God.
I'm not tall.
I'm too...
Oh, hello?
Guys, like, there's no rational thought in my head right now.
I'm just trying to survive.
Oh, ring, ring!
Deputy Duck!
Are you okay?
Speak to me!
Oh, my leg!
You gotta live!
You gotta...
Leave me to die, please.
Oh, God.
He's coming.
Henry's coming.
Oh, God.
Please, I can't run!
I'm trying to run!
Oh, God.
Please.
I'm trying.
I'm trying to run.
I'm so fucking-
I can't see!
Everything is so dark!
Oh, my God.
Wait, it's fine.
Where am I?
Holy shit!
Oh, close!
Close!
Oh, I'm in the bathroom.
Okay.
Okay, everything is fine.
We're all okay.
It's got too dark.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
That's not okay.
Oh.
Whoa.
Well, that's not good.
Whoa!
It's getting a little faster!
Is it supposed to get faster?
Hey!
Hey, there!
Whoa!
Why is it getting- Whoa!
Hey, that's- Whoa!
Guys, calm down!
Calm down, guys!
It's just a kid's game!
It's broadcasted to national television, guys!
It's fucking- We don't want anyone so wild.
It's real death, right?
It's not like Danganronpa built that entire fanbase over it.
Where's my duck?
Where's Womp Womp?
I miss Womp Womp!
I miss him!
Oh my god!
The last 20 seconds!
Oh my god.
It's okay.
You know.
It's alright.
We can do this.
Guys, I was just-
I panicked, okay?
We all know I panicked.
I absolutely panicked there.
Guys, the moment the duck was gone, it went all downhill.
You guys know that.
I miss him too, guys.
I miss him as well, guys.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's fine.
That's good.
We want the blues.
We don't want the yellows.
The blue, I can jump through it.
This is where I died.
This is when it gets a little too quirky.
It gets a little crazy here.
They get a little too excited about this whole game show that they're doing.
No, no, no.
Not again.
No, not again.
Don't do this to me.
Not again.
No, no, no.
That's the yellow prick.
Not the yellow- Did you think I cared about the yellow push?
I'm trying to survive!
We did it.
Stop.
Alright, nice.
We did it.
He fucking cares about the bunny plushie!
I care, doki.
I care.
Oh my god.
Okay, I thought I was dead.
I was a missile.
It was over.
Explore.
Oh, thank god for exploring.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Good.
It's just- You know what?
I'm gonna- I'm gonna rebind something real fast.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
That's cool.
Fucking- Oh, okay.
You know what?
Left mouse- Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Alright, that's good.
There's no- Wait, then what do I grab, though?
You know what?
There's no way anything is on the right mouse button, right?
There's- Oh, there is.
It's the PewDieDuck.
God damn it.
What do I- Oh my god.
I need something easier.
I can't- Okay, maybe this would be easier.
Maybe.
It could be easier.
We're exploring, so...
Yeah, it's- That's much more easy.
That's definitely a lot more easier than left click.
Oh my god.
Why is it so far down?
I wanted to use my mouse- Wait.
Am I supposed to be here?
Oh, fuck.
I'm committed now.
Waste incinerator.
Why is this- Why am I so tiny in this world?
Oh, hey.
There he is.
Whoa, there I go.
Whoa!
I feel so safe.
Okay.
Do again.
We go again.
Yippee!
Rollercoaster!
There's no pressure here.
See?
No pressure at all.
We just press the buttons.
Right?
Just...
Just press the funny buttons.
Where do I go?
Do I just do a flip?
Do I jump?
When do I jump?
It'll be so funny.
It's on the other side?
I guess it is.
It has to be, right?
I fucked up.
I fucking- This is where I fucked up.
Really?
I have to do it all over again.
Holy shit.
I can't- I can't believe it.
I did the simplest thing.
And then- Alright.
Alright.
Here we go again.
I just enjoyed it.
It was just too easy, you know, guys?
Oh, I don't have to do it again.
Oh, thank fucking god.
I don't have to do that again.
Holy shit.
I was gonna be like, that would be so sad.
That would be so sad.
I have to do that all over again.
Alright.
Here we go.
Frankie.
Hello, Frankie.
Hello.
Frankie.
Have a fun time with Doki and the Dragoons.
It's gonna be a really fun time.
You know, murder doesn't have to be involved, Frankie.
If you keep murdering people, then you're gonna run out of contestants.
I don't like this long fucking back doors hallway.
It's making me a little nervous.
This is in- Oh my god.
This reminds me of the back rooms.
Exit?
Is this where I came from?
Oh, this is where I came from.
Yeah, this is like the back room shit right here.
Oh, follow the- Oh, hey Frankie.
Oh hey, you don't look evil.
Hi.
You have a smiling face.
That's a good face.
Hello?
Yeah?
Oh, it's you!
The cops are here?
Wait, is that me?
Am I famous?
Can I have a pizza?
Wait.
Can I have a family sized pizza?
What does it say?
Invite her alive.
Oh, that's me!
Keep alive until the very end.
Terminate at- I'm Frankie!
Wait, I'm- Oh no, you're Frankie!
Oh, I'm me!
Game show number 57.
Wait, but what if I go here?
Where does the blue go?
Wait, where are the cops?
How did they not found me yet?
What if I just take this?
Oh, why did I take that?
Okay.
Alright, I'm back here.
Alright, I'm gonna go back.
No!
Why did I take that?
Back at it again.
I love- Guys, I just really love this particular area.
It's like snake.
Guys, it's like snake.
Guys, I just really enjoy that one area.
No, now I need to figure out how to get to that guy again.
It was right there.
The elevator was literally right there.
There were arrows pointing to it, chat!
You would have done the- There were arrows.
You don't understand.
I saw an arrow and I was like- Woah, I wanna fucking go there.
It looked so fun.
You would have done the same thing.
You saw the arrows.
Alright, nice.
Alright, here I'll go.
Time to take the elevator.
Unlock the trampoline and waterpark elevator door?
Yeah?
Find the trampoline and waterpark breakers.
Oh.
It's- Oh.
Oh!
Oh.
Y'all know how we feel now.
There's only one emotion for this.
It's just- Oh.
No.
Not water level.
What else could it be?
Not this?
It's not the thing that says danger?
Oh, it's this!
I don't see shit.
Can I do it?
Oh no.
Oh.
Oh!
Okay, here I'll go.
We can unlock the checkpoint.
You know what that means.
He's gonna- He's gonna fucking- Karusha Kali dog me right here.
Hello?
Oh, hello.
Who's that?
Oh, that's evil Frankie.
Oh, thanks good Frankie.
Thanks, I really appreciate that.
Oh my god.
What would I do without you, good Frankie?
Yay!
Yippee!
I feel so safe!
My good Frankie!
Never felt so safe in my life!
But what about- Oh my god.
Okay, another one.
I don't like that bad hat over there.
Wait, where's the last breaker?
Oh my god, are you fucking serious?
The last breaker is where the giant fucking hat is just being like, Hey everybody!
Hey, want me to- I'm gonna fucking get ya!
I'm gonna get ya!
Are you serious?
Are you fucking- Oh my god, like, how?
Where do I go?
Oh, it's here.
Oh my god, it's here.
Run, how?
How?
I was in the fucking water.
Oh, whoops.
Oh that's- I didn't know.
Oh no.
Hello?
This- Is this gonna be the trampoline and water part?
This elevator music is too- It's too relaxing for where I'm going to.
Oh hey, he got crushed.
Lucky.
He's free.
He's- He's free now.
Frankie's parkour palace, yay!
Yay!
I love parkour!
I love parkour so much!
Yay, parkour!
Yippee!
I love it so much!
Okay.
Where do I go?
Oh, it's down here.
Stairs over here.
Right?
No?
I assume it was down here.
There's stairs here.
What do we explore?
I don't see any, like, holes.
Guys, it's not Stockholm Syndrome.
I love parkour so much.
I just said, it's not Stockholm Syndrome.
I just- I just love parkour so much.
There's a lever?
It's just- Oh, there's the fucking- GUYS, IT'S CAUSE IT'S RED!
IT SHOULD BE YELLOW!
OH SHIT!
Oh no.
How many hoops though?
Oh my god, is this the last one?
Oh my god.
Not the hoop game.
Catch the noob noobs?
What the fuck's a noob noob?
Oh fuck!
Get the noob noob!
I got him!
Get the noob!
Okay.
Get over here!
Stop crying!
Get over here before I get you!
Please!
It's you or me!
One of us has to die!
STOP!
Stop jumping!
Where's the last one?
Where is he?
Where are you?
Where's the last noob noob?
Wait, where is he?
Oh, jump for the wins!
I didn't realize.
I was still trying to find noob noobs.
I- I- There you go.
It's fine.
Oh no, not the noob noobs again.
Where the fuck are the noob noobs?
Get over here.
Get over here!
No, get over here, noob noobs.
It's you or me.
That's fucking right.
You got nowhere to go!
What do you mean?
Oh, there you are.
No, no, no.
NOOOOO!
Did I get him?
No, I didn't do it again!
NOOOOO!
We were so close!
No way!
I literally- That's so fucked.
I was literally, like, there.
It was there.
It was action.
That's- I can't believe it.
Oh my god, this stupid noob noob.
The worst part is they're just- They're just always bouncing.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
They're in a better place, guys.
Oh god, I wish that were me right now.
Fucking crab.
Get over here, noob noob.
Get- get- STOP!
Okay, rings, rings, rings, rings, rings.
I can't fuck this up now.
I'm reading.
I'm reading now.
Oh my god.
Please.
I'm not gonna cry.
I'm not okay.
I don't- I don't do well in pressure.
Where's the other one?
Oh, there you are.
There you are.
I'm just gonna run.
Where's the last one?
I see you.
Stop jumping.
You think you can get away?
Oh, thank god.
Now the jumpsuit!
I'm running!
I can't-
It's okay.
One more ring.
No.
No!
Get out of this hell.
This is actually purgatory right now.
I don't know what's wrong with me.
I don't know.
This is actually purgatory.
Get me out of here.
He loves parkour so much.
He gets emotional damage from it.
Feels great.
Thank you for the superchat.
Oh my god.
There's so much more noob noobs.
Okay.
We're fine.
We have a system, guys.
We have a system.
Where are they?
You noob kids over here.
Get over- GET OVER HERE!
IT'S GOOD FOR YOU!
I'M BRINGING YOU OUT OF YOUR MISERY!
Get over here.
I see you.
I will fucking destroy the entire noob noob population if it's the last thing I do.
There will no longer be any more noob noobs after this.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
There's more noob noobs.
There's actually more noob noobs.
Come on.
Where is he?
God, where are you guys?
Get over here.
I'm only at 14 seconds.
GET OVER HERE AND SLAM IT AWAY!
Where's the last noob noob?
Noob noob!
Where are you hiding?
Stop!
Okay.
Run!
Run, noob noobs!
I'll make sure they stop existing.
What?
Oh.
It's the beginning to the end for the noob noobs.
Noob noob population.
Don't worry, don't care.
I believe in you.
I don't know why I do, but I...
I don't know why, but I do.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
At least somebody believes in me.
The noob at their final noob noob.
Oh, I got the key.
I did it.
Oh.
They're gone.
I defeated the evil.
I guess I go on this side, right?
This has to be Waterworld, right?
This has to be a different area.
Yay!
Waterflow!
Waterworld!
Yay!
That looks so sanitary.
Yeah, see?
We're at the beach.
Yay!
Waterworld!
Woohoo!
Is there water in Waterworld?
Oh my god, there's five?
Oh my god, but...
Two.
How do I get to five?
Three.
Where's the last two?
Oh my god, where's the last two?
This is out of order!
How do I...
Oh, it's the other side, it's the other side.
It's right there.
How do I get there?
Four.
I don't understand.
Now I'm here.
Yay!
Put your hands in the air.
I'm sorry, close your eyes.
Holy fuck, what the...
Oh my god, okay, we're never doing that again.
We're never...
We're never doing that again.
We need to figure out how to get there.
Is it here?
If I fly to...
Can I fly there?
It's like...
It's the trampolines.
You're right, you're supposed to...
Actually, you're actually supposed to keep your hands down.
Or you're like an effect of physics and you're gonna fly off.
And you'll fear a lot.
How do I get there?
Like, it's clearly the trampoline, but it's like, how?
How do I get up top there?
Like, it's that switch right here.
Oh.
No?
Oh!
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Three.
Wait, does that mean that one was, like, not related?
Oh, it wasn't.
The fuck?
They were unrelated to each other?
Where's the last one?
I already forgot where the last one was.
Wait, where's the last one?
Wait, wait, where's the last one?
I don't remember!
I don't wanna call a monster any...
Oh, hey, a bunny.
I don't remember, there's too many.
There's too many, there's too many swatches and I get confused and then I get confused and I'm sad.
It makes me sad and confused.
Confused.
Oh my god, how do I get lost?
How do I...
Three.
Okay.
We gotta hit the...
We gotta hit the pole thing, we gotta hit this.
There we go.
How did I miss?
Okay.
There's one here, where's the last one then?
Where's the last one?
What?
I...
Okay.
Okay, guys.
Guys, I can do this.
I can do this.
There's three?
Where's the last one?
It's on the bucket?
I see...
I see it!
I see it too!
Okay, I figured it out, guys.
I figured it out.
Guys, I figured it out.
Watch this.
Please, please, you're right there.
Please!
Please, how do I...
Please, you were right there.
You were literally right there.
Okay.
Two.
I love parkour so much.
Parkour is my favorite type of gameplay in the whole wide world.
And you know what?
I think...
I think more games should have parkour.
Okay.
We activated the fan.
So it should be this fan.
Where do I fly to?
Oh, it has to be here.
And then what?
Here?
Wait, what?
Oh!
Wait, no.
No.
I did it, but like, where's the other one?
I'm looking up.
Where's the other one?
Are you fucking serious?
How do I...
How?
How do I even...
Oh my god.
Oh, it's this.
I can't even reach it!
How do you even reach that?
That's how.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, okay.
Okay, that one was bullshit.
That one was actually...
Oh no, I can't even do this!
It's okay, I can.
JK, I was just testing you guys.
There we go.
Another fan has been...
Where's the next fan?
Oh, it's over here.
This has to be the other fans.
Oh.
It's like...
What?
They made zero sound!
Okay.
Alright.
Oh thank god, I don't have to do that again.
Oh thank god.
To the meet grinder I go.
Oh my god, I have to go from here.
This way.
I got baited so hard.
Oh my god, I fucking...
How?
I even did that in slow-mo too!
Wee!
I'm just a little special.
Alright.
How?
Okay.
Wee!
Oh my god, it's like...
It's like that doctor...
It's like that doctor game where you can't touch the corner.
No, it's like that Neopets game where you have to follow the stick.
If you don't, it makes the bzzz sound.
Oh my god.
There we go.
We did it.
We did it, team.
On the fucking mystery island.
I know, you're like...
Doki, only 5% of your chat understands that reference.
Doki, only...
Doki, only 5% of your chat understands what that means.
Oh, there's another cereal box.
Oh, that's the other key!
I got the other key now.
To open Frankie Mountain?
Wait, where's Frankie Mountain?
Where's Frankie Mountain?
Oh, lower everything?
Okay.
Alright, we boost the game up a little more.
Alright, that should be good.
Where's Frankie Mountain?
There's the water slide.
Oh, there's Frankie Mountain!
That should be Frankie Mountain.
Me?!
I'm just a fanfic!
I'm so relatable!
What can I say?
Wait, what?
Wait, this is all scripted?
There's no way!
A reality TV show is supposed to be about reality, Henry Hotline!
No!
They were gonna gradually...
Sorry.
Too relevant?
No!
Not my Oshi!
Don't worry, it's gonna reincarnate, guys!
Guys, it's gonna reincarnate, right?
It's gonna come back, right?
Guys!
Right, guys?
It's not gonna disappear forever!
I'm not supposed to go this way?
I thought this was the mountain.
You okay?
Alright,
see?
He's okay!
We still have Deputy Duck!
My Kami Oshi!
Is that alright?
No, he's okay, guys!
He's okay!
What?
What did I do?
It's not the same!
I thought I had to go here.
Use both keys to open the door.
I did, though!
Did I not use both keys?
This is... That's the key!
Don't worry, Toki!
I heard there was this cool new mascot named Henry Cellphone about to debut!
Superchat, thank you!
Thank you, fudge!
That's the door!
How can there be another door?
Is there another door I missed?
Wait, does he quack?
We'll find out.
That's literally the door!
Is it not this door?
Did I miss the wrong one?
Yeah, that's the mountain!
Hey, Frankie!
Hey!
Was it a crouch?
Oh, maybe I had to crouch.
Maybe.
I thought it was fully closed.
Yeah, no, I can't...
I can't go there.
I thought
I got both keys!
Where else do I go?
I'm lost, guys.
My Oshie died.
My Oshie graduated, so now I don't know what to do.
I don't know what to do anymore.
I guess my Kami Oshie right here might not be the same.
She doesn't have the same joy, but that's okay, you're still here!
I'm just gonna be stuck here!
Alright, go somewhere else.
I skipped something?
What did I skip?
I did Waterworld!
Oh, is that the incinerator?
Alright, back to... back to Frankie!
I'm blind.
I'm blind as fucking hell.
Alright, goodbye.
I swear to god, if it's not the incinerator and I fucking went all this way for no reason...
I swear to god.
Maybe it's like...
Oh my god, I swear to god, if I get one guide...
I swear to god.
I literally grabbed both keys, guys.
There's a waterpark lever that I didn't...
I do here?
Oh, that has to be it, right?
I'm a star!
He's gonna die.
No way he makes it.
He doesn't make it past Hexa.
Oh, that's you guys!
That's...
Why are you guys anonymous, you fucking cowards?
That's you!
Two Frankies?
What?
How?
Oh my god, chat's real!
I knew you guys were real.
I knew it.
You guys kept telling me, take my meds.
When I take my meds, you guys disappear.
This contestant is boring, bro!
Fucking fuck you, whoever you are!
Hiding behind anonymous?
Reveal yourself!
Talk to yourself!
No, shit.
Oh, I did it.
It's right here.
So true, chat.
Very nice.
That's fun, that guy.
Alright.
Oh, hey!
What?
Is that my heartbeat?
Oh, I don't like that.
I don't like that.
I don't like my heartbeat going so...
Oh!
19,000 people!
Hey, guys!
Hey, what's up?
Today, we are gonna do the support core challenge.
Oh my god!
19k people are watching me!
Time to get the crown.
This is the worst that can happen.
No monsters here, anyway.
Yeah!
We're going viral!
Hardcore ahead.
Oh my god, guys.
We're going viral.
We're going fucking viral, guys.
Wait, do we do it?
Where are we supposed to go?
Wait, was that not the part?
Oh, this was the parkour part!
Whoops.
That was just the beginning.
Okay, guys, remember to put your shoes away.
Alright.
Let's go.
Escape the slide?
Where?
Oh my god, wait.
Wait.
No, I always...
I always fuck up this part.
Oh no.
This is my worst Fall Guys map.
This part.
No!
Where's the slab?
Okay, guys.
Guys, it's okay.
It's okay.
We made a little...
We made a little oopsie, but that's...
No!
It's right here.
Oh, we just...
We made a little oopsie.
I told you.
This is my worst part.
This is my worst Fall Guys map.
This is my worst one.
Don't touch me.
That pity.
This is my worst...
My worst Fall Guys map.
I don't know why.
I just...
I don't know how to do this one.
It just...
My brain just can't comprehend.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
No, my brain just doesn't register anything.
When it comes to the slip and slide.
There's too many slips and too many slides.
It just...
It just fucks with me so much.
You don't understand.
Oh my god.
No, no, no.
Oh, thank god.
Thank god there is a guy.
Thank god.
Help.
Oh my god, please.
Please, it's right there.
Okay.
We're fine.
It's just...
It's just this now.
It's not as bad.
This part is not bad.
We just gotta be patient.
We just gotta be patient, guys.
Okay.
It's gotta be...
No.
Again.
The slip and slide.
I need... Okay.
This might be the wrong time to tell you guys.
I've never got past this map in Fall Guys before.
I always get eliminated.
Like, is that a...
Is it noticeable?
Like, can you guys tell?
Can you guys tell that, like...
I might...
That, like...
I get...
This might not be my strongest map.
I don't know if that's noticeable or not.
Is it that noticeable?
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Woah, woah, woah.
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
Alright, slide.
Slide.
Okay, that's fine.
Who told me to slide?
We're gonna be on this map for...
40 minutes.
On this...
This is literally the last parkour, I think.
They were saying like, woah, this is the last one.
This is the final act.
Alright.
I don't know, my brain just...
Can't register how to slide.
How to slip inside.
Okay.
Okay, everything will be fine.
Go.
Oh my.
That's right.
Okay.
Go.
Oh my god.
I'm unlocking my third eye.
I'm unlocking my third parkour eye right here.
It's all...
It's so over.
Oh my god.
I'm unlocking my potential.
No slide.
This is it.
My true potential.
I unlocked it.
I unlocked my parkour skill right here.
How?
Oh.
Yes.
Woah.
Gotta...
Push this up.
No.
We gotta push this all the way up.
And then...
Oh.
That was so close.
This is it.
Just smash through.
Okay.
No pressure.
Oh.
Nice.
Regular parkour.
No more slide.
Oh, woah.
Woah.
This is a little too hardcore though.
You guys make me chill a little bit.
Woah.
I went backwards?
That's a...
I just...
I made progress backwards?
It's fine.
Okay.
It's okay.
I was testing the water.
I wanted...
I was trying to figure out the pattern, you know?
But...
That's it.
I was just trying to figure out the pattern.
Oh my god.
I don't keep accidentally going backwards!
I...
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Please.
Please!
Where's the hole?!
Oh, there's the hole.
There's the hole.
Oh, there's the other hole.
Oh my god, we made it.
We made it to the hole.
Hello?
Oh, okay.
Oh no, not the Hexahavoc.
Didn't it say I was gonna die at the Hexahavoc?
Wait, how do I make it to the...
Why am I not flying up?
Wait, this is where I'm supposed to die, right?
Hello?
Good luck?
I don't need luck.
All skill, baby.
Hello?
Pumped your chosen?
I
don't like that.
Oh fuck, no, not...
This is Minecraft PTSD.
Oh no.
We know what happened in Minecraft.
We know what happened in Minecraft!
Oh, it's already happening!
It's already happening.
It's already happening!
It's happening!
Wait, that's cheating!
Wait!
That's cheating!
He's actually cheating!
What the fuck, there's new moves here?
Oh shit!
What the fuck?
Okay, okay.
Okay, that's so bullshit!
He's like, he's like fucking off-track!
He can jump!
Oh my god, this is...
This is so messed up.
This is actually so messed up.
This is...
I can't, I can't!
This is the last square!
This is literally the last square!
There's no way.
There's...
Wait,
can he kill me?
Do I have to run away from him?
Wait, can he kill me?
I don't know if he can kill me.
We'll find out now.
We'll find out.
Oh, he can!
Okay.
He can't kill me.
Guys, I'm not gonna...
Guys, I'm not gonna test it.
This stupid noob noob.
This actual stupid whore.
Like...
Get away from me!
This is not fair!
Oh my god.
Get out, no no!
Get your ass outta here!
Oh my god.
God damn it!
I didn't think he was gonna catch me!
Oh my god!
So bullshit!
The doodoos!
I'm fucking...
Okay, he can't kill you.
He got me in the corner!
Oh my god!
It's not fair!
Guys, I'm only doing it for the views.
Guys, if I...
The more I die, the more...
I'm gonna hit 50 concurrent viewers!
Guys, this is for the content!
I'm just raising the ratings!
Guys, I'm just...
I'm raising the ratings.
Chat, it's for the ratings.
You don't understand.
Chat...
Oh my god, get away from me!
Oh my god.
Like, it's so scary!
Are you fucking...
Oh my god.
You're such a whore!
Fuck!
I hate him.
I hate him so much.
This fucking sucks.
It's so over.
It's actually so over.
He's up there just having the time of his life right now.
He's having...
Are you serious?
That's actually bullshit!
Oh my god!
He like, landed on top of me.
So I put X...
Oh my god.
No!
I made a...
I made a beef jump!
I jumped for the beef!
I did it!
I got the beef!
Bye, Noob News.
Noob News.
Oh my god.
I didn't know that would work.
I put it all in.
Oh my god, we did.
Wait, do I die with him?
For the ratings.
I did it for the ratings.
I'm gonna die famous now.
For the content.
Remember me.
We did it.
We broke 20k concurrent viewers.
It was good.
It's fine.
I freed myself from parkour.
Who's that?
Wait, that's me.
That's me.
Wait, I lived?
Oh my god, biggest fucking plot twist.
I actually lived.
Wait, what?
What happened?
Did I break the game?
In my final breath...
I broke the game.
It just stopped.
It just...
Are you sure the game wasn't the first person?
Thank you for the super chat.
In my final breath...
The game broke.
No.
It's just that.
That's it.
What's going on?
I don't...
Hello?
Oh!
Oh, hey!
It's me!
Oh my god, here's the money!
I did it!
Oh my god.
I squidgamed.
I'm gonna get the crown.
5 million dollars!
Yippee!
Those don't look like real money.
Those look like Frankie bucks.
Okay, this stair is not...
This stair is not okay.
Hey!
Look, paper plates is not...
It's a choice.
Paper plates are...
Why is it like my apartment?
No, it's not accurate.
It has furniture.
It's not accurate.
Why the fuck is the staircase like twerking right now?
Why is the entire game twerking?
Why would I grab your hat?
I have 5 million dollars.
I did that.
Oh my god!
Are we gonna hit a million concurrent viewers?
That stonks.
The game has jiggle physics.
I did it.
And now, I own 10% of the company.
Bring in more contestants.
It's like Charlie and the Chocolate Factory.
When you win, you own part of the company.
57 seasons and a movie.
Yeah!
I'm the host now.
Why am I still?
Oh no!
Yay!
Oh my god, credits?
Credits to parkour?
That's fucked.
That's actually fucked.
Wee!
We'll just look at the credits from here.
Yeah!
Ba na na.
We'll get past once.
Please!
The timing!
I swear to god.
I swear.
I swear to god!
There we go.
We did it.
We figured it out.
Guys, it's not me.
It's not me.
I swear.
It's getting faster.
It's getting faster, guys.
I swear to god.
Look, look.
See, I'm doing it.
I'm doing it.
Look at that.
We don't even see credits anymore.
We don't...
We broke the credits.
We broke the credits, guys.
No!
How am I supposed to win parkour?
Stop farming clips.
I already won $50 million.
I don't need to farm clips anymore.
I own 10% of the company now.
I don't need to try.
That was fun!
I had a great time.
That was nice.
That was a good game.
Even though it was really short, it was pretty enjoyable.
It's another spin on the whole Mascot Horror Mascot Horror series.
I enjoyed the nice twist it had there.
I think it was a little expensive for a two-hour game, though.
I do admit that it was just a little bit more expensive than it should be because it was just two hours of content.
I think the music was really good as well.
I definitely enjoyed the music and the story.
I think it was like $15.
I think it was really fun, though.
I did enjoy it a lot.
That was fun.
When it started running at you and you got to complete the parkour part...
That freaked me out.
When they say deer in the headlights and you drive your car and the deer looks at you that's me.
I would get hit by a car.
I would definitely get hit by that car.
I had a really fun time.
Back to chatting.
Today...
Our line stickers...
I'm so sad.
The line stickers got rejected and I don't know why.
Let me read you what it said.
What they said to me.
We edited the stickers.
We edited the line stickers.
We don't know exactly what went wrong.
We couldn't sell it in Korea, Hong Kong, Macau, Indonesia because something was wrong.
But I didn't want to not be able to sell it in specific places.
We assumed that it had to deal.
We resubmitted it.
We resubmitted it to be...
to be...
to be approved.
But we think it's because we think it's because some hand gestures...
They were saying that some hand gestures are offensive or like...
affects different cultures around the world.
So I was like...
I was talking to the artist and we both assumed it had to do with the okay hand.
The okay gesture and the thumbs up.
Because we found out that in some places the thumbs up and the okay hand is considered offensive.
So we changed that to something different and then we resubmitted it too.
So I didn't know that.
I didn't realize okay and thumbs up were offensive at all.
Because I don't fucking know.
I don't keep up to date anymore.
I don't keep up to date.
I'm too busy being a VTuber.
I'm not joking at that point.
I'm too busy with everything else in my life to try to figure out what is if that gesture is offensive.
So I didn't know.
So I was really confused.
I was just like, what do you mean?
Let me show you guys.
I'm trying to see if I can find...
So the two want two of them.
If it does get approved and those were like the stickers that got denied, made the whole reason the sticker pack got denied online, then we're just gonna release the other two as...
We're just gonna release the other two as free downloadable stickers.
I was planning on making some free stickers as well for people, for Dragoons to be able to download it.
So those who can't afford the other ones, the paid line ones, they're like $2.
But it's still money.
You guys can still try and you guys can still
use the free ones.
So I'm gonna try and find it right now.
I didn't download the GIFs version.
I used the APNG and APNG isn't animated.
It's not animated on the...
on OBS.
Sorry, my brain is dead.
We changed this one.
This is animated by the way, but I can't be bothered to upload the animated version.
But this is animated by the way, so I just give you guys a thumbs up.
And the other one was...
This one that also got...
This one that also...
We assume...
We assume these were the ones that got denied.
We assume because we're like, what's offensive?
We were looking through...
I don't know.
I was like...
I don't know which one's offensive.
I assume because these were the only ones that had gestures that they're the offensive one.
Because the other ones are just like... I don't know.
The other ones weren't...
No, they didn't even specify.
I was like, hello, what is it?
I messaged.
It was like a message.
I was like, hello, what is offensive?
And then...
I got no reply.
So I was just like, alright.
That's a hand gesture.
So I think...
I think that's... It has to be.
It has to be.
So like, yeah.
I was just like...
I don't keep up to date with stuff anymore.
So like, that's my bad.
Because I'm terminally...
I'm terminally online.
But I'm also very...
Oblivious to a lot of things.
So...
I'm really sorry.
I didn't know.
But yeah, we did...
We changed it to...
So we changed both of them.
So instead of like...
I can show you what we changed it to.
So instead, we changed it to this.
We're like, okay.
Okay.
And...
The other one is...
This is the other version we have.
And this is the...
Good job!
So we changed it to this.
Instead of the hand gesture.
So I... I don't know.
I hope that it gets approved though.
I really do.
So we hope these get approved.
Because I really want to...
I really want to...
Put it up.
My official line stickers for you guys.
And also release the free pack as well.
But yeah!
Other than that...
There's so much stuff to do.
There's so much work to do.
I just want to procrastinate and hang out with you guys.
Oh, tomorrow!
Tomorrow is the Halloween stream.
So yeah!
I really look forward to the Halloween stream tomorrow.
Because...
We worked...
Me and the project people.
Well, there wasn't really...
Okay, yeah.
I'll just say that.
Me and the people who worked on this.
They worked really hard on it.
And I'm super excited.
I'm super excited for tomorrow.
That's all I'll say.
That's all I'll tease about.
Tomorrow, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's all I'll say about tomorrow.
But I hope you're excited for tomorrow.
Oh my god!
Did you guys see the Death Note Among Us game?
I'm trying to gather people for it right now.
It's coming out.
The fact that they dropped it out of nowhere.
They were like, The game's coming out next week.
And I was like, what?
They literally dropped the trailer.
Out of nowhere.
Like today.
There was no information about it.
At all.
By the way, there's a Death Note.
Here's the trailer for a Death Note Among Us game.
That's coming out next week.
And I'm like, next week?
A Death Note game in 2024.
That's the craziest part.
The fact that We're getting a fucking Death Note.
Any Death Note related Anything.
It's coming out next week.
And nobody They gave us zero warning.
They were just like, whoa.
Next week.
And I'm trying to gather people for it.
I asked in the Pico Park group chat.
If they're down.
I don't know.
It's not going to be everybody from the Pico Park collab.
I'm just asking if anybody's free.
Because I want to play it on launch.
I want to play the game on launch.
But here's the Here's the Trailer for it.
Here's the trailer for the Death Note Among Us games.
Also, I just found out I just found out that I saw a tweet Pop up in my 4U Algorithm.
Also, Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Already terrorizing my lab.
Time to celebrate.
Can't wait for the Stickers to terrorize the lab.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, what was that?
I just found out.
Oh my god, guys.
I'm sorry.
I didn't know this.
But like, I didn't realize that A lot of... I didn't realize that Like, it was literally what the Tweet said, but like Guys wear belts because Like, they don't have the hips For like, the pants to stay up.
I didn't know that.
Cause like, I never wear Belts at all.
I just Wear pants and then like I didn't know that.
I didn't know you guys Need belts to make sure The pants stay up.
Like, like...
I didn't know that was a thing.
I just see them as Accessories.
Like, I I didn't know.
I just see that as Like, accessory.
It was Never like a thing you need.
That blew my mind.
I know that's What they were invented for.
Like, maybe if you Like, you know, the pants is like extra loose Or whatever.
If it's like extra Loose, then you like put The belt on.
But I rarely ever had to put the belt on Cause like, I just, it just fits.
Like...
Yeah, I That like, that like Blew my mind.
I was like Holy fuck, wait Oh my god, that's why like So many guys were, I thought it was just A fashion.
I thought I legitimately thought It was just like, you know Guys are like, go, fucking Belts look so cool.
Like, you know, that's What I thought.
I didn't realize Pants fall off, you don't have your belt on Cause that's not a problem For me.
Like, that's not Cause why do you think men Cause it looks cool Like, do you not see The Wolf of Wall Street?
Like, he looked Cool in suspenders That's why I thought it just didn't look Fucking cool Like
Today Today I learned Today Today I thought it was just Fashion I thought it was just fashion But I learned a lot today Some of us Men do get, yeah, you're like the 10% You appreciate those Hips, boy Danny, appreciate Them.
You're saving money on belts Right now Oh Um, hey guys I'm gonna, I'm gonna head off Now, um, get Not, I don't wanna say get hyped, cause then you're Going in with like, so much expectations But like, uh, I hope you guys Will enjoy the special Halloween stream tomorrow And also like,
uh, Mintz Was it 3.0?
I think it's 3.0, how many, yeah 3.0 debut is coming out tomorrow as well So yeah, check it out Anyway guys, as always, everybody Stay hydrated, posture check Get up and, oh yeah, I should show Check jokeymerch.com I realize I have not shilled A lot, and I feel bad Because I have a lot of like,
like Collaborations and stuff With other companies, and I was like Oh shit, I need to shill more Anyway, the last two minutes of my stream Check out jokeymerch.com And like, buy some merch Buy some PC merch with Hyatt too They did a lot, they've done a lot for me So like,
you know, you guys didn't know I have a PC collab with Hyatt So yeah, check it out Please check it out There's a cool PC case There's like keycaps and everything Buy that merch Anyway guys, as always everybody Stay hydrated, posture check Get up and move around to get that blood flowing Head to bed,
cause you deserve it I'll see you guys next time everybody Bye guys, bye!
Also, so you guys Mentioned the The Lunar New Year merch Oh I just got, oh you guys wanna see the snapshot It's so cute, let me show you guys the It's not finalized But I was sent like Concepts of the I was sent like The concepts of the snapshot cause it's getting printed Out now,
so this is what the snapshot Looks like for those who buy the bundle It's so cute Well I haven't just picked one yet cause The moment I pick one they're printing it out But like, look how cute the snapshot Don't steal!
Don't steal Don't This is This is like, oh it's so cute I really like it, it's really cute
Anyway guys, I'll see you guys next time everybody Bye guys Bye Do not print it out, do not download my snapshot Bye bye